RamfisMyrthil, Film Producer, Film Consultant
and Speaker:They were in Harlem shooting the
scenes and the neighbors had their windows open
in the projects and you could just hear
all these women saying “I love you Denzel!”
Film Courage: Have you ever crashed a set?
Ramfis: I’ve crashed a lot of film sets that used
to be my M.O. [ modus operandi] that was the thing
that I did very early on in my career. I haven't
done that in a long time. I usually get invited
now to set. There was one particular time that I
want to share about where this was again or very
early in my career when I was just starting (I was
very green) and business and I just wanted to make
things happen so what I would do is look at the
there are websites where you could find where a
film is shooting the street the days they're
shooting maybe the project they'll make up a
different name for it and they'll change the name
of the actors that are in it or they'll just have
their character name just to be discreet but I
would do a ton of research and figure it out and
just pop up just pop up and there was someone
I wanted to work with or get in front of I had
a plan of how I wanted to talk to him what I
wanted to say I'd say that a lot of the times
it did work it was successful there was this time
where a friend of mine that lived in staten island
she was she was not in the business but she
was in entertainment and loved the arts and
she knew that I would crash film sets and this
friend of mine in staten island she went on
to tell me hey they're shooting this movie in
staten island and james is writing and directing
it and it must have been 10 11 o'clock at night
and I called my ex-business partner I said I found
out this information and he's I'm available I
said let's go so we drove from long island to
staten island over the verrazado bridge we got to
the film set and it wasn't a huge set but it was a
decent size set and we we just kind of blended in
and just waited for them to rap we were just being
respectful and back then james was always known
for wearing a suit and ty when he directed it
was funny that was his thing so at the end when
they rap we approached james and I introduced
myself and told him how much we loved his work
and the stuff they'd written before and then
we went to build a relationship with him and
if we could get his contact information and he
shared his phone number and email which was really
freaking cool and then what happened later on is
that I had produced a short that we took to the
short film corner at the cannes film festival
and we had told james that we were going and
he said hey guys well you should meet with my
producing partner this guy named sebastian
and sebastian works with him a lot and
he said that sebastian had three films
in competition which it's hard to get one
filming competition but sebastian had three
sebastian is french so we met with sebastian
at some fancy hotel in can I don't remember
the name of it but I remember it was yesterday
it was it was just a great highlight of my
career just remembering it it was bright it
was a beautiful hotel and sebastian is telling us
about his movies and then working with james and
telling us about some little movie they
did michael bay put his name on it and
universal will get behind it because
of michael bay and ethan hawk is in it
and then it's a little movie they'll see how
it does and at the end of the whole thing he
said that well there's an after party for one of
my films tonight here's two tickets love for you
two to come and they were these golden tickets I
imagine imagine these old tickets from the 1600s
or whatever 1700s and they were golden tickets and
had the name of the venue and all these things and
this was kind of balls ballsy of me to do but at
the time we had this intern named cassandra and
she spoke every language under the sun and
she came out there with us and it's very
interesting because when we were planning to go
to can we we're looking where to stay and she's
we never really knew her deal um but she said
yeah well since you guys are gonna go to can
I have a house out there and we're wait you have
a house in can it's right outside of canyon it's
in ducat which is a very fancy area and she ended
up living in a manson which is ridiculous so we
stayed with our intern in her manson I mean her
family owns it so it's not really her house but
she has a boat and all these things and we
learned all these things about cassandra and
she took very good care of us and drove us
to all of our meetings and things he can
so I asked sebastian and said listen I know you
have two you're probably limited what you can
give but cassandra is here with us she's a really
good person she's kind and she's appropriate and
we are staying with her and I don't want her
to just be at home when we're at this thing or
drop us off and is there any way you can spare an
extra ticket and he looked at me and then he took
the phone made a phone call and I used to speak
fluent friends I don't speak fluent friends but he
spoke something in france hung up the phone and he
went back in his pocket and gave us a third ticket
so cassandra was able to attend with us and it
was my first time at can this time around and
it was everybody that was an a-lister with this
was it this thing l-f-m-a-o I don't know how
you say they were there I think the smurfs
was coming out the producer of the smurfs
and the venue was this castle on a
mountain and there was a long line to
get into this thing with our golden tickets
we skipped the line walked straight in and
it was one of the best nights that I had in
cannes and I've been to can that was my first
time they can I'd gone one other time after but
yeah it was amazing and sebastian was a pipeline
for us and then we ended up selling that
short film to sorts international until
this day I still get a residual check every six
months to a year it's not a lot of money but
a few hundred dollars we've we've made decent
money on that short we so it was sold worldwide
and about a year later nba finals that film that
little movie that sebastian and james demonica
were talking about was called the purge and it
changed james's life and I called up james I'm
james I want to rock with you how can I get
involved with you and do more and he's listen
rampant there's not much I can do I'm a writer
director but if you ever need any support call
my agent and I developed a relationship there and
um the assistant this guy named michael had he was
a great assistant he now is an agent at the verve
town agency and we've become friends and anytime I
need something at verve I could go to him and that
all started because I took the risk to go out to
staten island to meet this guy so that's probably
the most successful story in terms of that and
there's been many other times where I've
just popped up on sets and it hasn't worked
I was an extra on american gangster and that was
when I first started acting and it was the first
movie I big movie I did extra work on and it
was just amazing to see ridley scott work and
all the talent just everybody was in that
movie idris elba and denzel and russell
and t.i it was an incredible experience and
the day that I was there there was no way
there was an opportunity for me to get in front
of denzel and the reality of it is that everybody
wants to talk to denzel I just remember when
they were in harlem shooting the scenes and the
neighbors had their windows open in the projects
and you could just hear all these women saying
I love you denzel it was just so classic it
was oh my goodness I felt I was in training day
watching that scene where he's in the projects
and everybody in the hood is a blood gang member
that's what it felt and it was just wow just being
there and and everybody just went to go ask for an
autograph or take a picture and that wasn't my
goal or intention and I wanted to speak to him
I’ll tell you why in a second so I said let me go
talk to ridley scott so I wanted to release scott
there weren't as many people lined up for him I
mean there were people lined up for him but not
compared to denzel and I just complimented him
on his work what he's done very familiar with
all his work and his accomplishments and not that
he cares it I'm me the extras complimenting him he
probably doesn't care but I just was genuine with
it and I was very ballsy with what I said I said
listen I want to work with you how can that and
this is when I was just acting I wasn't really
thinking about producing as much I just thought
about it a little bit but I was just telling him
that and I i guess inappropriate to tell him that
and what happened next was that I'd asked him for
his phone number I said listen I want to give
you a call let's sit down take you to lunch and
and I doesn't quite work that way and his first
a.d was there in time to save him and get him out
and he said no contact me and that
meeting with ridley scott never happened
what I ended up doing again which was really
ballsy this is before wme was formed there was
william morris agency and endeavour I called
his office and I said met ridley we hit it off
well and I want to work with him so how do we get
started something along that I got the assistant
and I guess the assistant knew this is not gonna
work and and I'd send my headset and resume and my
black and white that I just got made and and
I followed up and said after I submitted and
checked in I'm all right I'm ready to work with
ridley and and the guy at the time he just said
no it's not going to work and I realized I wasn't
going to get through this is not going to work so
I changed my strategy and I said hey you are
going to be an agent one day what I'm trying to do
let's build a relationship and that's what
happened me and the assistant developed the
relationship I came out to la and then we went
to some sushi restaurant that people used to love
going to I can't remember the name of it but we
had this really nice dinner it was somewhere in
west hollywood and I developed a relationship
with this guy that was on his way to becoming
a talent agent unfortunately he got caught up
it spiraled down for him and he had to leave
the industry so it didn't quite manifest into
that but I i believe I accomplished my goal and
and it was a good friendship that me and this
gentleman had created and now back to denzel
I did want to get in front of denzel the reason
was that I heard he was getting ready to direct
and I wanted to work with him he was on his way
to do this movie called the great debaters and
I wanted an opportunity to at least audition and
and be in the film so there was a day that I was
not scheduled to be on set and I found out where
they were going to be shooting I crashed the set
and I blended in and I there's a smart way to
do it where people are not going to kick you
off set that's what I figured just reading the
temperature of the set and the body language and
you're not doing anything inappropriate so I just
kind of just walked around and and then at some
point denzel walked out out of this restaurant
or whatever he was completely by himself oh my
goodness this is my moment so I took that moment
went up to him I said denzel he turned around
and I introduced myself I spoke with him and
then someone turned around because there's always
eyes on him he's a-list talent someone realized
that wait a second I'm not supposed to be there
I'm speaking to him no no no no and they ran
over and interrupted and said that he had to
go and then I had to leave and there was someone
else that I got to know on set there and he came
up to me and he said listen and what you did was
it's not appropriate and it's probably good if you
leave and and he's you don't I had the option not
that I had the option to leave or not to leave but
I just thought what's the highest good here I can
stay and try to do this again but now it kind of
squandered my plans so I didn't think it would be
smart if I did stay and try to get in front of him
again because of just the way the interaction
went so I ultimately decided just to leave but
it's funny because I ended up developing a
really good relationship with denzel whitaker
who got the role that I wanted and we actually
worked on this project with david oyelowo
two years ago and it kind of just came back
full circle denzel whitaker and I have become
the dearest of friends and we're homies but even
though it didn't work out I'm glad that I took
that shot because I live in a place of I don't
want to be in a coulda woulda sort of I know
that I i tried and I'm happy with what I at least
did I know that it just didn't work out it wasn't
it wasn't in I guess my best for it to work
out or the project's best and I'm happy that
denzel whittaker took that role because after
that he became who he is now I your stories
that what have you thought of of working
with the screenwriter if you had one about
just the whole thing you talked about with
cassandra you hear you have this intern
she speaks all these languages you're thinking
great we've got these two golden tickets to khan
and then you find out she's got this family
man I mean that that's its own movie right
there yeah you can't make it up driving around
two eager producers in france I don't know so
there's no way I've driven
around in france because
the vespas the way to drive the vessels I
feel I would have hit one of these guys and
the car we rented was stixxif and granted I know
how to drive stakes if but I'm not great at it
and we're up these hills where if you went a
little bit too far right you'll fall over the
cliff with no barrier I was extremely terrified
to drive in italy the way that they drive and
I'm not italy I'm sorry france we went to italy
after we flew into milan got the car from milan
and drove to can cop foray and so there's
no way I would have done that I don't feel
comfortable driving out there the way that they
drive especially a stixxif vehicle on show so
yeah cassandra was so clutch and so meaningful
to that trip that we had my first time at camp.